all it takes is one tragic misstep to
tank a once beloved actors career
turning them from icon to has been in
just a matter of months
some actors whether this fickle
Hollywood storm better than others and
keep their careers afloat following even
the most devastating flops others
however are not so fortunate and see
their star status fall fast after one
particularly embarrassing bomb actors
such as Freddie Prinze jr. back when
movie studios were tripping over each
other to put out teen slasher flicks and
rom-coms Freddie Prinze jr. was a young
man in high demand he starred in 1997's
I know what you did last summer and it's
1998 sequel then went on to cement his
position as a Hollywood heartthrob with
1999 she's all that
how does she think she is thousand girls
in his school and I could fall monkeys
with every one of them the new
millennium brought a change in fortunes
for the actor while filmmakers were
still keen to put out Freddie fronted
romantic comedies audiences became less
interested in seeing them the actor
starred in a string of critical flops in
the first few years of the decade and
then decided to try something a little
different playing bleach-blonde
paranormal investigator fred in the
scooby-doo movie Frank what's the secret
to be a success team worked I do a
tremendous amount of team work despite a
good showing at the box office the 2002
adaptation of the classic hanna-barbera
cartoon was panned by critics and left
Prince junior struggling for credibility
something he more or less gave up on
when he returned for the film's 2004
sequel the actor later revealed that he
didn't have fun making either movie and
he retreated to smaller projects
afterward including writing for the WWE
and pinning his own cookbook Alicia
Silverstone everyone within a six-mile
blast radius of the studio felt the
career aftershocks of Joel Schumacher's
epically awful bomb Batman and Robin
but former clueless Darlene Alicia
Silverstone went from a Betty to a
Barney faster than anyone
your vats become compost her Razzie
winning turned his bad girl to George
Clooney's begrudging Batman helped spoil
the release of excess baggage the poorly
received crime comedy that was supposed
to be her big starring vehicle 1995's
it girl quickly became 1997's has been
although silverstone received an Emmy
nomination in 2003 for her short-lived
ABC series mismatch and appeared in
2005's beauty shop Batman and Robin
foiled her chance of lasting stardom
John Travolta it's a story of multiple
resurrections John Travolta became one
of the world's most recognizable movie
stars in the late 70s after Saturday
Night Fever in Greece but by the mid 80s
his star faded somewhat thanks to a
string of poorly received pictures he
shot back to the top at the turn of the
decade after 1989 a chatty baby comedy
look who's talking raked in an
unexpected fortune of almost 300 million
worldwide but it wasn't until the
mid-90s that he became relevant again
thanks to Quentin Tarantino and pulp
fiction a string of successful films
followed but he took a serious misstep
with 2000's disastrous Battlefield Earth
widely panned as one of the worst movies
ever made this drastically miscalculated
l ron hubbard adaptation cost 73 million
to make and returned less than 30
million sinking Travolta's career once
more despite his best efforts he's been
unable to claw his way back since do me
more she rose to prominence as part of
the brat pack an influential group of
young actors who had the run of
Hollywood in the mid to late 80s a
breakout star of the bunch to me Moore
went on to mold paranormal pottery
opposite Patrick Swayze in 1990s ghost a
surprise box-office sensation Moore
remained a hot property throughout the
early 90s and by the middle of the
decade she officially became Hollywood's
highest-paid actress but her 1996 erotic
comedy striptease tanked and Moore's
reputation went down with it
she was branded box-office poison
overnight to the point that Disney
started sweating over the release of her
next starring role as a soldier in GI
Jane one senior executive reportedly
told Newsweek people just don't want to
see her we would have to drag them
kicking and screaming to see this movie
after GI Jane also failed to turn a
profit more left the spotlight later
becoming better known
her marriage to and divorce from Ashton
Kutcher than for her acting work Taylor
Kitsch when he won the part of running
back Tim Riggins in NBC's football drama
Friday Night Lights Taylor Kitsch gained
a cult following which may have
ultimately worked against him Gawker
argued the actor was a victim of the
friends effect claiming Kitsch fans just
didn't want to see him outside his
signature role something the studios
didn't count on
in 2012 the actor fronted Disney's
disastrous John Carter adaptation the
studio lost 200 million in John Carter
became synonymous with box-office bomb
the disappointing performance of
Battleship later that year proved to be
the final nail in kitchens coffin
despite his best efforts of channeling
Tim Riggins in the doom board game
adaptation and when a chicken curry out
Johnny chicken burrito didn't happen
chicken burrito kitchens closed Apple
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]